are you this guy's first two videos they
get hundred thousand views in a row we
get Carmichael a new camera
but what Carmichael really wants to do
is he wants to take two of the new Canon
80 DS one in each hand and like double
like old times
that's cool too I gotta focus yeah I'm
gonna frame is pacing Gloria shows ways
this an HDMI cord a hydrogen oh this is
a huge one we don't have any big issue
my cables were just a video production
company that just heavily honestly don't
shut up well here we go world's shortest
HDMI cable I'd love one of these
monitors work
all right so Nick and I last night got
all the costumes together thankfully we
got all the sets together got a halo
soldier it's been awesome we're trying
to take care of me doesn't have very
much time to live we're gonna make the
best of it we've got the master chief
costume we've got all of our little
locations doctor's office place where
they fight the Covenant and we've got
the other places we're gonna go and film
today and tomorrow all figured out so
now we're finally ready I'm gonna go get
in costume we're gonna go do this here's
the thing like I mean I have to sit here
because we go Wireless Keyboard would be
nice here max I got four cables out of
the equation just dealing with this dump
Mac sorry
step two I'm gonna get a wireless
keyboard a mouse this is Casey Edwards
Casey Edwards has basically done music
for every video arts like the past two
years bringing Casey on board to do the
music for this movie let's make this
happen
one light off let's set the mood light a
candle some incense rolling in here yeah
music what is it
it looks like we got ourselves a nice
rain scene here which you know clearly
clouds all over the place and it's sort
of a hopeful moment having fun use me
sorry sit right here okay Oh
I got a drop of water in my lightning
port and now my phone keeps saying your
accessory may not be supported or an
official Apple product so the fire
umbrella works pretty well pretty
exceptionally fast in a fire
extinguisher out and everything but it
any went wrong by the time we even
grabbed extinguish from the fires out so
I guess it's safe if you think of it
that way I mean like a hail lettuce
right now we've got action so Sam and I
have a post meeting at one o'clock and
before we do that there's two big things
when I get all the way people number one
I'll sit down with you and go over the
Master Chief edit and talk about visual
effects and all that good stuff thing
number two is I want to go up onto the
roof and fly the drone some more I think
you guys might enjoy knowing how to
build one also so I'm happy to share it
with you guys and kind of give you a
little overview on what you need to
build a racing gun
what do you think
so imagine Midas touch but instead of
turning things into gold you turn them
into Lego models that can fall and
shatter